welcome back to portland well while  stephen curry was scoring 50 points in  the nba all-star weekend in cleveland he  was also  planning a very special moment for  the brave brave  hooper that you're seeing walking right  now his name is matt spellman  he got to watch steph warm up pregame  matt was born nearly three months  premature you guys he weighed three  pounds and nine ounces he was told he  would most likely never walk again let  alone play basketball eventually he  loved basketball he loved the game and  one thing he could control was his  shooting so he became a great shooter  and eventually made the varsity  basketball team all the inspiration  coming from his favorite player stephen  curry and the best part of this all is  not only did he get to watch warm-ups  pre-game but he'll be with stefan after  the game as well to spend a little  quality time together